35 ans 35 ans de cyan
diot après plusieurs années de sciences
dans les magazines dans l'écrit
donc ou à la télévision de radio canada
c'est vraiment tout un voyage dans un
monde qui évolue à toute vitesse dans un
bond de la fois merveilleux et est tout
à fait encourageants et extraordinaire
le monde de la science
un exemple d'émerveillement l'univers
c'est le co vaste univers beaucoup plus
grand aujourd'hui on ne comprend mieux
aussi on le voit mieux et il est
beaucoup plus beau aussi grâce à toutes
ces photos extraordinaires que nous a
envoyé par exemple télescope spatial
hubble pour vous montrer des galaxies
des amas de galaxies des superamas de
galaxies des photos donc fabuleuse des
photos aussi le petit système solaire
les planètes qui nous entourent enfin
des planètes les planètes soeurs de la
terre qu'on a photographié qu'on a
découverte qu'on a que certaines sondes
ont frôlé ça a été vraiment des années
merveilleuses pour pour ça après on
s'est rendu compte que les problèmes
d'environnement pouvait être à plus
grande échelle à l'échelle parlant d'un
continent et on se rappelle de toutes
les deux de tout l'épisode des pluies
acides par exemple où on voyait que un
pays émettait des avait des émissions
acide lesquels arrivait sur les forêts
ou ou dans les rivières d'un autre pays
et puis après on s'est rendu compte que
les problèmes d'environnement en fait
concerne la planète entière
on a eu le cas avec le fameux trou dans
la couche d'ozone mais heureusement avec
le protocole de montréal en 89 on a
quand même assez bien régler ce problème
là mais surtout la grande question le
grand sujet sont les changements
climatiques et on revient que il va
falloir faire preuve de solidarité
internationale à l'échelle mondiale à
l'échelle de la planète pour régler ou
contenir ces problèmes-là côté médecine
chanter bien sûr là c'est une succession
absolument incroyable de découverte de
deux bons coups de points gagnés contre
la maladie contre certains cancers
contre des maladies qui étaient très
handicapante contre les maladies
cardiovasculaires par on l'a fait des
progrès considérables mais il reste que
les problèmes de santé qui confronte nos
sociétés actuellement restent ne sont
pas entièrement et uniquement traités
par delà ce que j'appelle la médecine
médical la médecine
curatives on parle obésité on parle
diabète on parle de maladie mentale on
parle toxicomanie problèmes de
toxicomanie
donc toutes ces questions là c'est des
questions qui confronte la science et la
médecine et qui vont devoir être réglé
donc la science est plus que jamais
nécessaire utile et ce qui est le plus
et ce qui est très important bien sûr
c'est que les jeunes les jeunes garçons
et les jeunes filles aussi face des
carrières scientifiques
embarquant science des fois c'est
difficile la science mais c'est quand
même ça qui va probablement nous aider à
mieux vivre sur cette terre qui est
quand même pas mal joli même si elle est
parfois un peu endommagée par les
activités humaines et par les activités
de la technologie
[Musique]